[Musique]
je me souviens de l'édition de la ryder
cup de 2002 édition qui s'est jouée sur
le parcours du belfry en angleterre
c'est une édition qui avait une saveur
un peu particulière car
c'est la première épreuve de ryder cup
qui s'est joué après les événements de
on s'en souvient la ryder cup de 2001
était programmé là quelques jours après
la tragédie du 11 septembre est
évidemment suite à cette tragédie
les équipes américaines et européennes
ont fait le choix ont pris la décision
de reporter le match
il n'y a donc pas eu de ryder cup en
2001 et l'épreuve a été reportée en 2002
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
avec la ryder cup qui se doit qui se
jouera en 2018 en france
désormais les éditions de la ryder cup
se joue les années paires et plus les
années impaires
alors que la première édition de la
ryder cup c'est joe une année impaire en
donc cette cette épreuve avait là aussi
une dimension un petit peu historique
l'équipe américaine était ultra forte
alors vous me direz comme à chaque fois
mais là c'était vraiment impressionnant
notamment avec tiger woods qui était au
top de sa forme ou phil mikelson qui lui
aussi faisait figure de favori et
l'équipe européenne emmenée par sam
torrance avait en face d'elle un gros
morceau à avaler
contre cette équipe américaine et c'est
comme bien souvent sur le parcours du
belfry que de nombreux matchs se sont
dénoués sur le trou ultime le trou
numéro 18
il ya notamment eu une sortie de bunker
rentrée de paul azinger le joueur
américain pour égaliser 1 point
et de la même manière un match homérique
de colis de montgomery qui était allé
chercher un point et alors que les
européens étaient au coude à coude avec
les américains dans les simples ils ont
dans la deuxième partie dans le dimanche
après midi et réussi à prendre
l'avantagé et je me souviens
parfaitement du point du demi point qui
a été ramené par paul mcginley à
l'époque il était joueur de ryder cup
avant d'en être le capitaine quelques
années plus tard ça s'est passé sur le
green du 18 il a rentré un pote de six
mètres pour s'imposer pour marquer ce
point de la victoire et l'équipe
européenne a envahi le green aux côtés
de l'équipe américaine
c'était une victoire non pas inespéré
pour l'équipe européenne mais en tout
cas c'était véritablement une victoire
avec panache qui s'est inscrit dans
cette période qui a marqué un petit peu
la suprématie de l'équipe européenne
contre l'équipe américaine
[Musique]